while i was live streaming the other day
at twitch.tv for slash simon clark link
in the description a user called steve
vagabond asked one of the big questions
in life could i cook a potato by
dropping it from space to answer that
question let me ask another question
when we cook a potato
what are we actually doing we take an
object that is at room temperature and
put it in a hot environment
until
its temperature reaches a critical
threshold according to various sources
on the internet for potatoes this
critical temperature is 98 degrees
celsius at which point the cells in the
potato rupture and the texture
irreversibly changes to be squishier and
tastier crucially a food stuff like a
potato is only cooked when its center
reaches this critical value so it has to
be cooked all the way through everywhere
being at least 98 degrees celsius the
reason we don't cook potatoes at this 98
degrees c is because there's a delay
between the outside of the potato being
heated and the inside being heated we
can describe this using the thermal
diffusion equation which basically says
the rate of heating at a location
depends on how much temperature is
changing in the local area multiplied by
some constant a number specific to the
foodstuff called the thermal diffusivity
if we assume that a potato is spherical
which is
kind of true we can model how the inside
temperature changes with a computer
program that rewrites the thermal
diffusion equation in terms that a
computer can understand a process called
finite differencing if we put our
spherical potato radius five centimeters
in an oven at a certain temperature we
can see how the internal temperature
changes over time and how long it takes
for that critical 98 degrees c to be
reached with the oven at 150 degrees c
it takes 45 minutes while at 200 degrees
c it takes 35 minutes uh what a computer
is to me is it's the most remarkable
tool that we've ever come up with and
it's the equivalent of a bicycle for our
minds but what about if we dropped our
potato from space so instead of having a
constant temperature on the outside like
in an oven we'd instead have a variable
temperature on the outside of the potato
that temperature would initially be very
cold as it falls through the upper
reaches of the atmosphere but then as it
plunges deeper and compresses the air in
front of it into a superheated shock
wave that temperature gets very hot
indeed this is of course why spacecrafts
such as the sawyers and the dragon
capsule have to have heat shielding to
protect them from this effect when they
return to earth anyone who's played
kebble space program will know what i'm
talking about okay now at this point we
have to make a few assumptions i'm
assuming that our potato is covered in
foil but not just any foil this is a
special kind of foil that won't melt
during re-entry it won't disintegrate
during re-entry and it perfectly
redistributes all of the heat around the
potato such that it is cooked evenly
from all directions of course this isn't
realistic but until mr beast teams up
with spacex dropping a potato from space
for a youtube video isn't realistic
either the assumptions make the problem
less realistic but more solvable and it
also negates the kind of boring answer
of it might just disintegrate during
re-entry reality is often disappointing
we can adapt our original python script
to calculate how the potato's internal
temperature will change as it falls
through the atmosphere first of all we
need to keep track of the potatoes
altitude how high it is off the ground
and how fast it's falling let's say that
its altitude is initially 100 kilometers
which is approximately the boundary of
space and that altitude decreases based
on how fast the potato is falling that
falling speed is of course influenced by
gravity but also by air resistance which
will vary depending on how high up the
potato is initially it will fall faster
and faster opposed by very little air
resistance and then as the atmosphere
gets thicker air resistance will
increasingly slow it down we can
calculate the air resistance because we
know the potatoes altitude and so can
look up the local temperature and
density of the atmosphere these together
with the potato speed tell us how much
air resistance it experiences and so how
its speed ultimately changes but now the
important question at what temperature
is the potato being heated well to
calculate that we can use a quantity
called the total temperature which is
the temperature of the surroundings so
the atmosphere the potato is falling
through plus the heating caused by the
potato compressing the air in front of
it as it falls into a shock wave that
total temperature then becomes the
effective temperature of the oven that
we're putting our potato in that changes
over time so let's drop a potato from
space no by the way that i'm assuming it
starts at room temperature so it's as if
you snap your fingers and the potato
just teleports to the top of the
atmosphere initially the potato
accelerates quickly falling almost
unopposed then as it hits the upper
atmosphere friction causes it to heat up
dramatically however this heating
doesn't last very long and as the potato
falls through the mostly frozen
stratosphere and then troposphere it
cools down and then slightly heats up
again by the time it reaches the surface
the outside of the potato is room
temperature once more
by the way if you want to know why the
temperature of the atmosphere looks like
this with the stratosphere getting
warmer with altitude then you should
check out my book firmament it's an
introduction to and history of
atmospheric science it's out now and
link below okay but what about the core
the center of our potato did it ever
reach the temperature necessary to cook
it
not even close the temperature on the
outside may have been large enough but
the heating didn't last long enough for
it to reach the center of the potato in
fact because our potatoes spent so long
several minutes falling through the
frozen stratosphere and upper
troposphere that the center is now
actually colder than when we started and
the outside is maybe slightly singed but
also frozen by the middle atmosphere but
you may well ask why wasn't the outside
of the potato glowing red hot like
returning spacecraft our potato was only
heated to maybe 150 degrees celsius
while re-entering spacecraft experience
temperatures of over 1500 degrees
celsius this is because returning
spacecraft don't enter the atmosphere
with no initial velocity like our potato
they are going very very fast like
a few kilometers per second kind of fast
so what if we were to drop our potato
harder if we heat our tuber into the
atmosphere at a speed of one kilometer
per second
this is what happens within the first
minutes the temperature of the exterior
peaks at about 220 degrees celsius the
potato falling at about one and a
quarter kilometers per second then as it
enters the denser stratosphere it
decelerates rapidly cooling to the
ambient temperature by the time it
enters the troposphere at this point the
temperature of the center starts to rise
as the heat from re-entry reaches the
potatoes core but this is a very small
effect
we can keep upping the velocity until
we're spiking our potato at the ground
at a speed of 10 kilometers per second
beyond which the assumptions that my
code makes about how the atmosphere
behaves kind of break down but even at
that speed while the outside of the
potato reaches 1500 degrees celsius the
center actually warms less than when
thrown at one kilometer per second the
problem is the faster you throw the
potato into the atmosphere the hotter
the outside gets sure but it spends less
and less time being heated at 10
kilometers per second the re-entry
fireball 1500 degrees celsius lasts
maybe 10 seconds
it's just not long enough also if you
put a potato in the oven at 1 500
degrees celsius even for a few seconds
yeah the outside of that potato is going
to be burned to a crisp to cook our
potato through what we need is more time
in the atmosphere which we can
accomplish by aiming the potato not
straight down
but at an angle with a couple of
modifications to the code we can account
for things like centrifugal force and
the curvature of the earth and simulate
this we find out that if we're pitching
at 10 kilometers per second there's an
entry angle of about 80 degrees beyond
which the potato never reaches the
ground because it skips straight through
the atmosphere and just out the other
side into space so we're limited in our
angle of attack to between 0 and 80
degrees and in our initial velocity to
between 0 and 10 kilometers per second
so to find the ultimate answer to the
question can you cook a potato by
dropping it from space we need to
consider all possible combinations of
entry angles and initial speeds and
calculate
what happens to our potato
this is it
we find out that if you throw the potato
at a large angle of attack at high speed
effectively putting it into a decaying
circular orbit with lots of time in the
upper atmosphere where it can cook its
core temperature will rise by nearly
a degree celsius
the problem is still time even in that
decaying circular orbit the total
journey time from space to the ground is
about eight minutes and if you were to
cook a potato at 1500 degrees celsius
for eight minutes you'd still struggle
to raise the core temperature by more
than a few degrees and that's not even
accounting for then having to spend
several minutes falling through freezing
conditions in the stratosphere and upper
troposphere to answer your question then
steve vagabond i'm afraid no
even if the potato could be teleported
to the top of the atmosphere prevented
from disintegrating and covered in an
incredible new heat shield material it's
just not enough time to get thermal
energy through to the center of a potato
in the best case scenario your spud
would be room temperature in the center
and absolutely annihilated on the
outside in general while cooking it's
best to let the atmosphere just be
a spectator
before finishing i just want to give a
quick shout out to randall monroe who
answered a very similar question a
couple of years ago on his excellent
blog what if which was really useful in
the early stages of this project if you
like this kind of question and unusual
applications of physics then definitely
check out randall monroe's blog and
actually book and of course if you find
what goes on above our heads interesting
then i'd highly recommend my book
firmament it only came out last month
and we've already had some fantastic
reviews if you've made it this far in
the video then i'd highly recommend both
of these books both link below if you'd
like to see more videos like this one
please consider signing up for my
patreon you get early access to videos
directly support my work and in the near
future will hopefully be seeing a new
patreon exclusive series that just leads
me to say thank you steve for asking the
question and thank you for watching the
video here's some recommended viewing
next if you enjoyed the video please do
mash the like button and don't roast me
in the comments thank you again for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one